hi everyone uh good afternoon um
i am utterly delighted to invite you all
to the follow-up discussion session and
conversation
from yesterday's uh excellent
presentation by dr sarah teichmann
on inference um the nature of inference
and rather the inference of nature cause
and effect in molecular biology and we
are delighted to have as a conversant
today professor neil lawrence who is the
deep mind professor of machine learning
at the university of cambridge
um professor lawrence is the inaugural
deep mind professor at the university of
cambridge he has been working on machine
learning models for over 20 years
he recently returned to academia after
three years as the director of machine
learning at amazon
and his main interest has been in the
interaction of machine learning with the
physical world
and this interest of his was triggered
by the deploying of machine learning in
the african context which i'm quite
curious to hear more about from him
where end-to-end solutions are normally
required
and he has inspired his work has
inspired many new directions research
directions at the interface of machine
learning and systems research and a lot
of his fun uh work is funded um
with an ai fellowship from the alan
turing institute
he is also
very well fetted has many awards and
recognition
and i won't dwell on those because i'm
dying to
get into conversation
and
participate in the discussion that he
and professor teichmann are going to
have
um so uh neil sarah absolutely delighted
to have you both here this afternoon and
la and looking forward to a smooth um
intellectually choppy but a um hopefully
a smooth uh presentation this evening
thank you both
thanks so much priya um and and thanks
very much for the invite to be the
conversant and for
also for a great presentation yesterday
so i'm going to open with a sort of uh
short discussion i won't use slides um
but i i wanted to riff off
the opening to one of the questions
which was uh
william cork said uh
before he phrased his question he said
i'm not a real scientist i'm a social
scientist
and uh i kind of think that that's um
there's a problem at the heart of what
he's saying there
because we're in a world where there's
many many complex things we'd like to
understand and make decisions on
and yet some of them apparently fall
beyond the rema of what science is
capable of answering because effectively
it's it's not william that's letting us
down it's it's science that's letting
william down if he feels that to be the
case
and i think what's so exciting about
sarah's presentation yesterday and and
what we're seeing in the sort of
the shift in biology to a much more i
mean it's always had quantitative
elements but the dominance of
quantitative work
um in in terms of scientific discovery i
think it has to be our hope that the
same type of shift will occur with a
sort of move towards computational and
quantitative social science and and
that's not by the way as i hope i'll
highlight as i discuss to diminish
qualitative research i think it's
absolutely vital
but um i thought that was a sort of
interesting starting point because
what's really going on
and what we saw a lot with what sarah
talked about is the complexity of
systems we're trying to be scientific
about and and if you think sarah sort of
ended talking about the immune system i
mean it's one of my favorite riffs just
to say well you think we don't
understand the brain you should hear
what we don't know about the immune
system and the immune system is sort of
widespread across the all animal
kingdoms and just an extraordinary type
of intelligence
but not just the complexity of those
systems but also the answer of well if
we're talking about inference about
those systems what is knowledge itself
so what does it mean to understand those
things
and i think that that also came through
a lot in in what sarah was saying
and i think particularly you see in
biological work so so part of what that
means is perhaps to be able to predict
what might happen
in the case of an intervention in that
system and you see that a lot in
biological models but
sarah actually used a number of
different ways of trying to explain how
these systems operate and the first
first couple she used was um
what i would talk about is
dimensionality reduction uh giving you a
map as you would call it and it's so
interesting and it goes all the way back
to gauss mapping technologies and gauss
was actually doing it for mapping the
earth but but what we're often trying to
do is build a map which means a sort of
functional approximation from a low
dimensional space to a high dimensional
space in which we collected the data and
it's interesting the extent we use that
analogy almost unthinkingly very very
often i don't think sarah was thinking
about this as a cartographic map when
when she said that um
but of course the one of the fantastic
projects that she's been leading is the
human cell atlas so there's atlas again
we see these analogies coming forward
and it's because there is a genuine
relationship between that practice that
we are mostly all familiar with or maybe
with google maps and we've all forgotten
how to read a map but it's the practice
that we're mostly familiar with of an
abstraction of the world one of my
favorite i can't remember where this
story comes from in the first place but
but bernard
was the one that i heard it from and
it's not from him originally was um
the notion of the the country that was
so good at maps he said when you build
them 150 000 well we started going with
one to ten thousand that wasn't good
enough and then we decided one to five
thousand that wasn't good enough one to
one thousand that wasn't good enough
eventually we've gone for a one-to-one
map
i think that is uh borja's story yeah
that's brilliant thank you for coming i
was forgetting i i would end up there so
that's great that we've got there
and of course that's that's nonsensical
that's useless the map is an abstraction
and an abstraction that is used for some
purpose so this knowledge that we're
interested in is therefore somehow
contextual for what we choose to con
abstract is depend on who we are and
what questions we're interested in
asking
sarah very brilliantly went on to talk
about um
i thought one of the most remarkable
pieces of work from my point of view was
the work on the um the way the dimers uh
and the timers come together uh and this
sort of leading to this predictive
almost like periodic table of the uh
protein structures and i think it's sort
of interesting again we see the need to
convert our knowledge into some sort of
system that we can relate to the
original periodic table and of course
and she talked about mendel and alien
genetics uh medallion inheritance which
is actually quite a nice simple form of
inheritance but it's actually quite
distant from the form of inheritance
that that we see in in much of animal
life
and i think there's an interesting
aspect there that we are we are drawn to
obviously explanations that we can
understand the bookshelf the map um the
mendelian genetics the periodic table
and i think there's a sort of follow-up
question but is that really the way the
world is
or is it just the windows that we can
see through when we look at the world
the things that enable us to have
intuition about what's happening in the
world and i don't know the answer to
that question and perhaps the answer
doesn't really
matter because it's sort of more
anthropomorphic comment but it perhaps
doesn't matter very much in the practice
of science when we're practically as um
as priya said in the introduction i'm
very keen on what happens when when real
world decision making comes in and sarah
again showed a wonderful example of how
you can use these technologies in
perhaps diagnosing cova
and other diseases and you know in
future other diseases of the immune
system if we can if we can use
understanding of the human cell atlas to
understand how we're being infected well
how wonderful would that be
but this leads me on to sort of what i
think two really emerging challenges are
in the domain here which i think
sarah was masterfully dealing with and
you know she's a she's the head of her
field um and but these are just really
challenging and they keep coming up
everywhere and there's two paradoxes
that i talk about as the um
the big data paradox and then i have a
follow-on paradox called the big model
paradox so sarah very nicely described
how the data and model interact and i i
tend to think of this as a spiral and
there's a wonderful quote from karl
popper which is the answer to the
question i can't remember whether he
uses um hypothesis i think he uses
hypothesis which comes first of the
hypothesis or the experiment to which i
would say the model or the data
um
is the same as the answer to the
question which comes first the chicken
or the egg the the answer is that they
co-evolve
so what do we mean by that is early on
there is a very diffuse kind of
experiment which unfortunately some
people call fishing expeditions well
it's it's a diffuse experiment that's
trying to understand where should one
focus and i really just like that term
fishing expedition
um and then once you've you've done that
initial experiment that might inform you
which is informed by some understanding
of the system that that helps focus that
helps refine your understanding system
and you focus down and down and i see
this is a
spiral moving forward but but what we're
trying one of the challenges we're
experiencing is is we get more and more
data in the world it strikes me that we
seem to understand less and less about
the world and there are many examples
about this um so for example uh we could
think about election predictions it
seems you'll be getting more and more
information about who's clicking on what
people are saying on twitter and uh yet
we seem to be
if anything getting worse at predicting
the outcome of elections and this is
quite a well understood statistical
concept how you predict the outcome of
election so that that's kind of odd or
stratified um medicine so trying to
target drugs at the right population um
you know as we get more and more
information about patients you'd hope
that we could get better and better at
that and that doesn't seem to be
happening
and i think the reason is the following
so i observed this some years ago and
spoke about it first uh
talk at data science africa as peter
said a lot of my interests are inspired
by applications in the african context
um but i couldn't sort of give an answer
to what i think is going on and it was
actually during the covert pandemic that
um i i i've come up with this my
hesitant answer and it comes from
realization the same thing happens with
models
so
the big dates paradox i think is arising
from the following
it's it's a sort of example of not being
able to see the wood for the trees or
tree
so what happens is we gain more and more
data about a phenomenon
and therefore we get more and more
interested in this data we have and
perhaps more and more focus this sort of
data in attention blindness going on
we've become very focused on that data
we've acquired
um and we think we've got a very rich
description but the description is not
representative of the wider system
and as a result we end up making very
very biased decisions we talked a little
bit about bias in data and one of the
ways that and sarah does a brilliant job
of bringing these data sets together
which is absolutely key but not many
people are doing that as well
you get this very sort of focused data
set on one small aspect of the entity
you believe you've understood a great
deal because you've got so much data but
in practice you've actually just
understood a lot about the wrong thing
so you perhaps you wanted to understand
the small ecosystem around a tree in a
forest but what you actually ended up
understanding is sort of the details of
how caterpillar is operating on one of
its leaves which is not relevant to the
the question of interest so you can see
how that relates to this notion of
abstraction and the map um the the
danger is you go diving in and what's
happening is people are losing their
human intuition about what goes on in
these systems they go diving in and
collect all the data in the world
without that intuition and they collect
the wrong type of data because they
perform the wrong type of abstraction
they get the map one to one scale in the
wrong place
um and very similar things are happening
with modeling and i believe we saw that
a lot in uh pandemic modeling in
epidemic modelling where you have people
creating richer and richer descriptions
of how diseases can move through the
population but if those descriptions
themselves were all based on the idea
that disease is moving through touch
rather than aerosol
most of the the aspects of that
description is useless to you and
actually what you want is a is in both
cases what you want is a model that's
more abstract that is taking account of
less detail but is more understandable
by everyone that needs to operate on
that model and that's not just the
designers of the model or the collectors
of the data but the domain experts so
encoded that would be public health
officials if you're saying to the public
health people you can't understand my
model then you've got the wrong model
you need to be able to communicate to
them because they need to be able to
make decisions true and i think that
that's something that goes beyond just
the need for us individually to
understand what's going on in science
but it must also be an ability to
explain to other scientists or the
general population about why these
decisions are going on so it's not just
about individual human understanding
it's about societal understanding of
what's going on and i think that's going
to become increasingly important
so i'll just check my notes because i'm
going to wrap up here but if there's
anything important i've missed
so um it's as yes so it's it's very good
just checking and i'm out to the point
where it's important that people can
relate to the models and inferences that
we're making and the big data and big
model paradox are very much about losing
the ability to do that
now science is super interdisciplinary
and sarah also mentioned that um but
increasingly our analogies that we're
using in these domains are dividing us
rather than uniting us and i think i
really welcome this series because i
think it's an opportunity to discuss how
that's coming about
um because we should really be able to
address this in the methods um that
we're delivering on um as a sort of
final exam i think one of the real
challenges we face is you go to sort of
priya's comments at the end of the talk
was well you know what's the equivalent
of the conservation of energy what's the
thing that we can do and integrate in
these models that we know to be true
and i think that's one of the key sort
of questions and challenges we face when
we're doing this because very often
the symmetries we understand that should
exist in the natural world are
incredibly difficult to introduce into
these data-driven models um but i think
that often the answer is to do exactly
what you saw sarah doing throughout her
talk which is yes that symmetry is not
embedded in the model but you represent
in that model you represent its
prediction in such a way
that
if
um if there's an error you see it so if
the thing is behaving in such such way
so when you when you produce those maps
i mean though the mapping that sarah is
using there was a sort of little twitter
thread on it the other day but it's kind
of notorious but it can potentially go
wrong
so that part of the art in that is what
brings sarah bringing her knowledge and
certain people that work with sarah
bringing their knowledge to
understanding when it's been done right
and when the plot is valid um and some
people don't like that type of
subjectivity they don't like that sort
of interaction occurring but i actually
think it's vital i think we have to
embrace that and better understand that
um otherwise we are never going to do
what i sort of said we should be
addressing at the beginning which is the
challenge of bringing
to that science to that most complex of
things social science um which is where
we would really like to be in the end
and then with that i'll stop i think
over and over
uh thank you so much neil for those
wonderful and rich set of comments sarah
did you want to take a shot um
yeah so i think neil um you know that
was that was absolutely fantastic and um
this is this resonates
perfectly with basically
the way we operate as in the
bioinformatics world in terms of
um
you know the questions that you say is
is the scientist has to decide which
data to collect and so in that from that
from that perspective actually big data
you know the data that's there is a
hypothesis in and of itself
in a certain sense it's not a phishing
expedition
because you have decided to collect
uh you know to make to do a certain kind
of measurement on a certain kind of
sample
and not that decision in and of itself
you know in in
um you know when you when you articulate
it in that way it becomes clear that
there's an underlying hypothesis there
um
and um
and and i think that you know that that
i think is a fantastic way of of um
describing
let's say genomics big you know high
throughput biology and so on and and
that it's actually not that different
from
your conventional kind of microscopy
experiment
looking at sort of the the cells you
know in a in one sample
in one tissue
um or in one one cell culture so it's
it's um
it's simply
a larger scale version of the same thing
basically
um you know i think that's that's uh you
know very illuminating to kind of uh
frame it in that way yeah sarah i just
wanted a point of clarification to
ensure that i understood and i mean neil
aren't you saying that this process
um also embeds subjectivity
and a sort of um
a take you have a take
when you um did you imply that or am i
uh misunderstanding
i think it does but i think it i can't i
think you can't separate yourself from
that subjectivity in a lot of these more
complex sciences and i i would agree
with sarah in terms of the data
collection itself is somehow um
expressing a hypothesis and and one that
potentially is very difficult to write
down mathematically
the same is true of a traditional
genetics you know
why did mendel decide to to score you
know the color on the peas
i mean that's also there's a hypothesis
in a way
or you know the the speedman's organizer
experiment that i'm going to choose to
measure what
embryos those are kind of traditional
you know experimental but but in a way
our sort of era of functional genomics
and big data
that that's you know it's juxta it's
often juxtaposed with that with that
traditional
way of proceeding but actually i think
what neil is saying is that it's not
that different and that completely
resonates with me i you know i
completely agree with that
and i think one of the interesting
things that happened
which i'm sort of fascinated by is
and i don't know that i'm not a
historian of science but
it's something that strikes me as
possible is that when statistical
methods were introduced they could
answer a certain type of hypothesis you
know with statistical confidence
and i think something incorrect happened
in that there was a section and this is
certainly not statisticians don't feel
this in my experience but there's
certain scientific domains where people
have decided that the only form of valid
science is to do something that you can
convert into a sort of randomized uh
experiment and and come up with a
p-value at the end of that and that's
had some awful effects like p-value
hacking is a consequence of people
trying to conform in domains whether i
am able to do that
um and it's also had people dismiss
things as non-scientific if
if that's not possible well there's
going to be many situations where we
aren't and sarah gave excellent examples
around climate you know so let's get a
thousand randomized planets and try this
sort of thing to see that it's just not
going to happen
um it doesn't mean it's not scientific
it just means that the different
approaches required and i think when you
the subjectivity
is part of the scientific scientists
expertise um and you kind of want to
introduce that i think i mean you have
to be aware it's there and you have to
sanity check right
you have to debate yeah and i think
often that gets confused uh with
reliability right i mean the
as in impacting reliability um i totally
take your point about this idea of
randomized controlled trials i mean in
those kinds of ways of thinking there is
an implicit assumption
that you are effectively marginalizing
over all other variables that you don't
even know exist you don't even know what
they are
and somehow you are making an implicit
assumption
about the variation
in those variables like you know there's
some they're all gaussian in some way or
something right so
you are marginalizing um but i think
what was very powerful about uh sarah's
description
of the process that she's following is
that uh she seems to be
very um aware and cognizant of what is
being done at every stage
uh sarah that was wonderful and that you
are even illuminated yeah and i think
articulating
the big data approach with the
bioinformatics you know as actually kind
of in many ways analogous to traditional
uh molecular biological approaches i
mean i think that
again that just um you know the way
neil's framed it that that that really
strikes a chord with me because it's
true that you know we decide what data
to collect
we then decide uh how to model it how to
you know projected from a high
dimensional space into motor ventral
station all those decisions you know
they there there's some there's an
interpretation element there which is
just like you know conventional
molecular biologists who would make
a small scale measurement interpret the
data and then decide what's the next
experiment and so you know in the in the
the big data high throughput genomics
era that's then you know what's the next
set of genomics data that you collect
once you've made that model but in a way
actually the the process itself is a is
the same kind of iteration
of you know collecting data
interpreting it even if you're using
machine learning and it's more complex
statistical models
and then and then
uh once you've done that interpretation
you're then going to go on to
um the next set of data collection and
when i say you it can be you know the
same research group or a different part
of the community that's reading that
paper that's the computational uh you
know data analysis and then
uh um you know taking that into account
for the next step
um so it's in a way it's
you know we haven't
fundamentally changed
you know the the human
or the the way we do science from a
human point of view in the era of big
data high throughput genomics
bioinformatics and so on but i think the
frame but i think you are all you've
changed the frame though because when
you look sort of classically those of us
building say conceptual models
in physics right
um
there is reductionism is really built in
those into those models so we start out
by saying let's make a paired down model
and the subjectivity there again as you
mentioned comes from the expertise when
the expert scientists she decides
what is redundant what is extraneous you
know what is essential
and pairs down the model and then so you
reduce you know you reduce um actively
and then you slowly add on bells and
whistles and then go collect the data
that would be appropriate that would
match the kind of more complicated
mapping you have to do but it seems to
me that in bioinformatics
you are sort of consciously not doing
that and being much more open
in allowing many more possibilities and
um does this lead both of you does this
lead to more flexible science in a way i
mean would you both
uh
think so
so i mean well one way i sort of i think
physics is this unusual case i i tend to
think of
of a spectrum of mechanism from strongly
mechanistic to weekly mechanistic so um
what do i mean by that i mean strongly
mechanistic you're more likely to be
seeing a lot of differential equations
and
but there's still an abstraction in
there i mean
as i understand planck's length means
the world is discrete but a lot of this
stuff is done in continuous spaces right
so that's an abstraction i mean it's a
really good one or if we look at
statistical mechanics and we look at the
behaviors of gas
so you get this sort of
strong overlap between what your
mechanistic model says and the way the
world behaves if you control the world
in certain ways of course if you start
getting certain materials then they they
break away from that and i think that
historically in physics there tends to
have been a focus in that space if you
go to a
very data-driven model i mean there's a
weak mechanistic assumption in those
models typically typically either
linearity or smoothness
and very often flexibility is introduced
i think you can often unpick and say as
i think you're implying earlier
that a latent variable is being
introduced to help
if there's something unknown going on
that messes things up
so there's this spectrum of mechanism i
think if you go all the way back to sort
of gaussian laplace the people who are
doing the sort of early physics and as
it turns out early statistics it was one
world to them and what's happening these
worlds have separated
actually a lot of the interesting stuff
is in between and i think that
this but it's such a difficult question
how much mechanism and where and it
comes back to that mapping thing so in
some sense what physics is trying to do
at that very microscopic level is build
the one-to-one map so say no we've got
everything in here for this controlled
circumstances but in in in very complex
systems even the one-to-one map wouldn't
even be useful because um you know the
answer that the scientist wants uh
to the sort of the questions that
sarah's asking about covet is not
because this molecule interacts with
that molecule at some very low level
it's much more abstract than that and i
think what fascinates me is the ease
with which human beings do that type of
abstraction
and the extent to which that's missing
from our automated methods so i went on
too long there
sarah i don't know that makes sense yeah
yeah no that makes total sense i mean
the
there are still
there are still sort of basic
abstractions that underlie our
interpretation of the data that that um
you know things like
what is a gene
you know what is a promoter which is the
start side of the gene
um so what you know what are enhancers i
mean there are sort of fundamental
models that we have in our mind that are
implicit when we when we analyze the
data
um they're a bit more subject to um i
mean i know it also happens in
in physics but you always get the sense
that oh what oh that's what we thought a
promoter was but actually this extra
additional thing can happen that we
didn't know about yeah you know things
seem to move and and it's quite hard to
describe in a very pure mathematical
sense how the promoter is going to
behave i mean
if i go back 15 years to when i was
modeling this stuff we used to model i
don't know we use like catalyst based
models i mean when you've heard what's
actually happening or you see i think
you did this wonderful thing sarah you
showed first this sort of simulation of
what's going on in the cell you know any
you know all these things moving around
and then you took it down to okay but
let's abstract that into these block
shapes and then we can
what's really interesting about that is
you were taking the essence of what was
important for the question you were
answering and you turned that into a set
of pictures that everyone in the
audience could immediately understand
what you were doing but of course you've
just shown the reality or what we think
might be the reality in that simulation
before where a whole load of additional
stuff is going on and i think there's
this weird thing where we keep on
getting drawn into the simple model that
describes the abstraction which gives us
one aspect but yeah we find it very easy
to forget well actually it doesn't look
anything like that in practice whereas
and i know priya so i don't wanna you
know in physics it kind of it feels like
but it does look closer to the block i
mean of course it doesn't look like that
but
you know what i mean
well i mean i think in physics you know
we have been very uh um obsessed
with uh a sort of the the determinism is
really baked into
uh you know what we project as our
understanding of the world and and the
mathematical language that we have
developed to make sense of the world and
it's of course it's surprisingly widely
successful right so we are really
weather to it which is why i guess
quantum mechanics is so disorienting
to uh physicists and everyone alike that
you know this whole idea of
deterministic relationships and you know
separation between subject object
observer observed all of these things
that come crashing down and we have to
move to a very probabilistic uh
description
um
but you know i think this is probably
one of the uh sort of blinkers that
physicists really have
would the biological context be more
like like the kinds of
approaches that engineers use
you know
for
i don't know i mean i thinking of you
know because a lot of the methods that
we use for big data analysis and biology
have actually come from engineering so
for instance
from image analysis or from speech
recognition
or from you know these kinds of things
it's not actually the methods
for for big data analysis
are less
from some sort of physics physics than
yeah i think yeah
right
yeah i think you're right because i
think the kinds of methods you are using
in bioinformatics
are not searching for laws
you're not looking for laws you're not
looking for universals
and i think there's a way in which sort
of physics
articulated through mathematics
is constantly looking for
laws and you know symmetries and
sort of
universality of descriptions you're
constantly looking for things that
would uh a new categories that would
have some kind of universal cadence
whereas that's why i think you know it's
a much more flexible approach
yeah possibly um i don't know neil do
you think that's more of an engineering
uh take as sarah suggests i mean a lot
of it is pattern recognition you know a
lot of it boils down to some form of
pattern recognition
and i guess um
depends which sort of engineering i mean
in one sense um when you first said
engineering i was thinking so like
systems engineering and sort of there
was this sort of great invasion of
chemical engineers yeah and what always
strikes me is
it's so interesting about biological
systems that it says well
because they evolve they have all this
they don't have light or we'll just
connect that to that it's like
whatever the system is like oh and if i
could it could make use of it did and
redundancy the things that survived with
the things that had a lot of redundancy
and i i always find that so fascinating
about when you work on biological
systems that side of it because it
really messes with your ability your
intervention you thought your
intervention should show something but
actually what happens is some other
subsystem compensates because your idea
of what system is you know these evolved
systems didn't go oh my goodness well i
will have to have that as a nice
separate subsystem but i think then you
came in later with i think the stuff
which i think is quite interesting and i
i do think it's
more the machine learning like
convolutional neural networks yeah
exactly more the
not the the more recent kind of
electrical engineering not the dynamical
system sort of right yeah so i know i do
think i think you're on to something
there and i think it also relates to
this point around abstraction i think
the really big
sort of advance that we've had in
machine learning which is perhaps it's
an odd advance because it's driven by
data and compute i feel um is
just the ability your ability to
fit models to very large amounts of data
and have this some sort of automated
abstraction about what's going on
the emergence certainly in
right i'm unconvinced in the biological
domain and i i think that's a really
interesting open question but in the
domain of vision and speech where there
are notions that are very familiar to us
as humans about
phones and phonemes and and objects and
images which we find absolutely trivial
to pick up as very small children
um and but we were having a lot of
difficulty teaching machines what these
abstractions were and how to interpret
them and the
way we've come towards being able to do
that is just by showing these machines
enormous amounts of data and having them
figure it out for themselves i mean
horrific amounts of data way more than
humans need um
and i think that there's a real
interesting thing that that's kind of
what we would like to be able to do in
biology and one of the things like sarah
and i the one thing i'm so excited about
the sort of data that sarah's producing
now is it's data at that scale where you
think or possibly
we can do that with biological systems
but i think it's
i partially thought it's an unanswered
question about whether we'll be able to
so i don't know what you think
well i mean going back to you know the
days of of genome sequencing so the not
not the kind of functional genomics
more
um
a sort of downstream genomics that i
work in uh the
you know
that that the c there's many many more
sequences out there than there are gene
expression patterns or protein
structures
uh in the in the public domain let's say
that the community is generated and and
those data sets you know the methods
like in markov models were incredibly
powerful recognizing patterns of of
sequence homology and methods in the
kind of when i was doing my phd in the
mid to late 90s early 2000s and so on
and that was
i mean to me that was uh you know the
first kind of
where the light bulb kind of went on
in terms of the power of machine
learning because they they are so much
more powerful than than sort of
conventional
you know pattern matching methods at a
learning pattern sophisticated patterns
um you know that are that are also hard
for a human to see necessarily
immediately because you are dealing with
huge data sets
you know and and then
it's really the machine that models them
so to speak
um and so so definitely those those um
you know astronaut not astronomical but
i mean large biological data sets exist
and they
and and and
you know they're growing and they're
growing at different in different
domains of biology now i think that's
also the exciting thing is that we're
we're beyond that pure dna you know
information
at the level of dna we're now
not only at rna but also cellular
entities which is sort of getting
getting us closer to biology you know
physiology in a way
um and away from the pure kind of
information informational
level of the dna sequence
um and and and then it's
and then it's basically the the
challenges and the excitement is is
analyzing that level of data that's
closer to the to the biology if you will
of a human tissue or an an animal
you know physiological system
um with with machine learning
so that's just you kind of thought sorry
period so following
because i think it kind of does escape
do you think it's escaping the big data
paradox i don't know if you recognize
you know that as a thing or if you agree
with
this notion that if we collect more and
more we don't necessarily understand
more and i i don't personally
is it escaping the big data paradox and
if so why because i definitely think
that it's definitely domains where we're
not escaping it i think
i think uh part of this has to do with
the fact that as you mentioned right the
e word
sort of the emergence you know emergence
of phenomena
that we are not able to capture with any
of the other
you know forms language description
models um
um and you know it's the power of
emergence and what um what we learned
from that
i i find that sort of i found that very
astounding especially
with as sarah mentioned but sort of you
know the the early work on sort of the
you know the machine learning turn uh
teaching neural networks to recognize a
dog versus a cat and you know all of
those kinds of
um experiments that were happening right
um
i think where that eventually led you to
um is you know analyzing data sets and
suddenly showing you some sort of um
what in my language would be called a
hidden correlation uh but you could not
have you know it's well hidden it's uh
it's one that uh you could have never
anticipated at all
uh and so perhaps you know a connection
in a higher dimensional um uh domain
going back to the language of maps
uh but i think that you know the other
sort of theme that i wanted to sort of
um
get both of your takes on and
particularly sarah the notion of
complexity
right and
you know so uh what is the future i mean
do we just have bigger and bigger and
more complex data
and our tools will keep evolving um what
is your sort of um what do you see as
the prospects
for um the kind of bioinformatics work
that you're doing
so i was needed for
for
you know the
i mean the bioinformatics always goes
with
uh you know the the technologies and the
data that's available and and it sort of
evolves as a field in a way in lockstep
i think with that i mean
that's that's a bit of a generalization
but that's certainly a tight tight
correlation and and i would say genomics
does have a
there's still a long journey ahead
in terms of
not only this the size of the data sets
but also
the the domains and areas of biology
that it can be applied to and and so you
know we talked about climate change
and uh you know hurricanes and events
and so on and that we can
we you know we can't perturb them
uh yeah and and one of the areas where
where genomics can can contribute or is
contributing now and sort of
not i won't use the word encroaching but
contributing to that area area of
science is
um you know environmental dna
and sort of surveillance of ecologies
and environments on our planet
um you know sequencing basically not
just animals but also all pathogens
plants
how they depend on each other eat each
other cold you know
have symbiotic relationships and so on
simply through
dna sequencing of a lot of ecological
samples
and you know that's really really
relevant now also with a pandemic and
you know infectious disease and
infections right now i think you make a
really uh important point that it has
actually caused us to shift away from
always thinking about competition to
cooperation right there have been
fundamental shifts
in how we uh review um you know what
drives
sort of uh change evolutionary change
and so on you're right but um and and
there's lots of areas of health care you
know that will
you know we can be on on
genomics can be used as a sort of
early detection method you know you
supply it by sequencing
various samples from from blood saliva
you know urine so there are lots of
areas where where the technologies can
be deployed
you know in in future
and and they are evolving towards those
areas and contributing to those areas so
basically diagnostics as a routine
diagnostic you know you just sequence
the sample
and and and sort of
in in more yes more
in very practical ways in everyday life
as well as in in in
more arcane research contexts and and so
in a way what what the impact that that
has is that biology is sort of becoming
as a science i mean i am speaking from
my vantage point but it's becoming a
a big data science basically and but yet
i agree with with neil is that the
measurements that you make there's
always a hypothesis so it's not like
you're blindly just
sequencing every aerosol drop in the
world it's it's there's still decisions
you know that are being made and it's a
scientific process with a hypothesis and
a model and an iterative
um you know journey forwards in a
spiral-like way using neil's analogy you
know i think that's that's that's really
accurate
um
yeah and i think it's sort of i think
that's where i see the future of this
area of biology
i think what is particularly liberating
about this direction
is that you know we can free ourselves
from sort of this porparian view of you
know it's all about falsifiability and
so on right so we've broken free of that
so yeah
and
i think that's actually intellectually
quite liberating
and um and very productive in terms of
uh knowledge production
so the uh so the other sort of question
that i would like to pose to both of you
is
um
how do we know how do you know that you
are generating new knowledge
it's actually you know establishing
what's new
when you're analyzing a big data set
with machine learning
is actually
it's that's actually part of the
scientific
challenge or task or puzzle in and of
itself
and and i would you know sort of um
you know i think that's a really
interesting question priya and very
pertinent because you know we can gather
the data we can model it and and and or
analyze it using statistical
computational machine learning methods
whatever but then actually
pinpointing what's not what's the novel
discovery
that requires going back to all the
decades and decades of old literature
you know reading all that digesting all
of it um
and then the you know the intellectual
exercises figuring out well
actually that that gene was known to be
in that cell you know but but this part
actually that that this is a really
golden nugget that's new you know and
then we need to articulate that clearly
because otherwise the the community you
know can't understand the story or
what's
so you know you have to
in a way there's also a very
conventional kind of scientific exercise
there
you know that requires the the
scientists to understand everything
that's gone before
right um
to to to present it basically so um so
neil my claim uh sort of provocative
claim would be
that what it means to discover
has fundamentally changes in the data
rich machine learning driven error
would you agree sarah well
is it so different i mean it's a
different it's different in the way you
the tasks that you perform
but
you know as neil said actually there's
still an implicit hypothesis in the data
collection also in the in the
interpretation computational
interpretation
there's there's
subjective elements and hypotheses that
you have in terms of which models you
use
and then
you know the the the the interpretation
of what's novel and what's the discovery
is again that kind of
there is that conventional scholarship
that comes into it that you need to know
everything that's come before and you
need to juxtapose
the parts that you know that it's your
that's that that's the novel
contribution and so on so is it actually
is it actually a complete rev you know
change
or or is it just a new way of of doing
that exercise
i'm curious to know what you guys think
yeah neil what is your take yeah i'm
curious to hear your takes
i think sometimes when we associate with
papa the sort of the falsification thing
as a sort of very but i think when you
read him i think he's not i think it's
the the tool of statistical hypothesis
things which turns that into a sort of
a very oppressive tool i don't think
popper ever means it like that i think
it's more well i always read it like
well
my model should kind of be predictive in
some way and i think what the challenge
that you're
[Music]
lucidating is in what way is it
predicted i think relates to your
previous question about complexity and i
think also this sort of this historical
view of everything through reductionism
that like we should be able to get it
down to this quite simple formula
and there's lots of reasons that if we
can do it that's quite nice
um
i mean i think one answer to like how do
we know when we've done
something new i mean
yes this is new to the scientific world
but one of the things that fascinates me
is i read somewhere that like until like
quite a long way through the 19th
century
the whole of the natural sciences tripos
in cambridge was just teaching you you
know and now
we learn that when we're 16.
and then you've learned you know you've
learned something new
if you're compressing that knowledge i'm
sure they must have learned other stuff
and i think part of that is because of
the way in which we teach it and the
understanding we have that we developed
and it takes quite a long time
and and that's the real embedding of
knowledge now when it comes to
individual things i think as sarah says
it's quite hard and i think that we can
look to popper though for the gold
standard that it has to be predictive in
some way but there is this close
interaction between the human
and the data because of the subjectivity
in what data is being collected and the
subjectivity in what the right aspect of
modeling it is and you know that's the
thing that i feel
um
actually potentially it was
is reduced in in in what we think of as
the purest sciences but we must
re-embrace it if we're going to do
do the social sciences properly which i
think is is a very very worthy property
and they do it very well you know but
i have bring the scientific methodology
um
to the social sciences and it makes me
wonder is the answer
a sort of meta reductionism that we we
can be reductionist but at a different
level problem with reductionism is it
doesn't allow for some of these things
we've been talking about because i think
that we need to be able to say no we're
putting that bit to one side we're going
to put navia stokes to one side while we
talk about this hurricane um
and and you know i i don't quite know
how i don't know if that makes it right
i mean you know this um so let me try to
ask the ask this question in us
so sarah if it turns out
that
the notion the concept the conception of
a cell
is not the right conception
how would you how would how would this
big data actually show you that
right let's say it's a blob and you know
i'm just giving some name right blob
doesn't necessarily mean an aggregation
of cells you know a completely different
kind of entity right
um
if it turns out that one of the ways in
which we have chosen to represent
is um is limited
because i mean there's no question of
flaw or whatever it's just that it's
right it's it's not accurate yeah so how
would it emerge from you know this
information-rich landscape that you are
exploring and mining
is there room for something like that
and is that what you're looking for when
you're looking for a discovery right i'm
trying to sort of see okay
but there are you know there are it is a
it is a good point because there are
cases where the concept of the cell
isn't actually
you know applicable basically or useful
right yeah or useful yeah yeah and and
they include
um sort of plant uh structures that are
you know continuums a continuum of
sort of tubes of nuclei um
in in the drosophila embryos or those
beautiful stripe patterns that i showed
it's actually kind of a bag of nuclei
that's it's there are no boundaries no
no
you know
membranes or walls between the
individual cells and actually the same
is true in
in muscle where you've got these these
myotubes that are along nuclei and um
but what it does come down to in those
so the word cell in in or the way we
analyze those those kinds of tissues
then is is by boiling the cell down to
the nucleus
and that's
that's the kind of um the entity then
where
the the dna the information is
transcribed into the message
so so you're kind of you're then
the word it's not a cell it's it's that
little little kind of tiny compartment
that that encompasses the
the um
the genetic information itself and
that's that's how we
how we deal with that and um
i think there's nothing that wouldn't
come out of the data
um you know that i think that would that
there'd be a limitation there there'd be
there are certain limits
and i think that's where neos think
about the subjectivity of the data that
you collect is relevant because
you go in
knowing you know you go in and you know
actually this kind of
approach with this kind of sample
you know it's going to hit its limits
and then you decide okay well in that
case we'll use this other approach we
may we may not disaggregate the
individual cells we may just cut through
and study genomics in a spatial in a
tissue section you know and and collect
a different kind of data it may still be
big data but it's a different experiment
and that's where the
i that that's why i like that that
you know that concept that actually
the scientists is is it's not a fishing
expedition it's not just like a wild
kind of blind sort of
um you know completely hypothesis-free
collection here it's not like um it's a
bit different from the sort of
um
you know we're listening for aliens kind
of thing with our our radio telescopes
it's more there's more there's more
direct fishing expedition but you
understand where the fish should be yeah
right i mean you you have an
understanding good idea
[Music]
you're looking for koi you know where
the ponds are right yeah and i think
that there's another way in which maybe
the cell
another way of looking at your question
prayer would be
i mean going back to the map analogy i
mean is is there evidence a way in which
motorways don't exist well yeah if
you're walking on
you know the the lake district you're
not so worried about where the motorways
are at that moment and i think that
that's where you see the subjectivity
and modeling coming in and these these
are sort of concepts and we see that in
physics as well depending on what we're
trying to teach whether we're trying to
teach newton whether we're trying to
teach quantum mechanics our model and
our understanding of what an atom is is
is changing um because you don't need to
look at it with that final level of
granularity so i think there's an
argument in terms of the you know
perhaps the cell doesn't exist when
we're talking about different organs in
the body we're doing organ of course of
course it exists but it's not relevant
in in the way that we're thinking about
the decisions that we're making um or
it's only relevant at the edges and i
think that
that's there's this wonderful um
everyone loves the george box quote um
uh you know all models are wrong but
some are useful and and the way everyone
uses that quote is they then describe a
model that's wrong they don't ever
describe why it's useful um
but there's a better bit in that well
better bit the whole paper is great but
there's another bit in that paper he
says um it's important to consider in
which way your model is wrong um
there's no use worrying about mice when
there are tigers abroad so
i think that that's the essence there
where the cell does disappear sometimes
you don't want to take into account the
cell because of the you're either at
such a low level
that you're in the nucleus and you're
worrying about something there or you're
at such a high level where it's sort of
the level of fidelity isn't there and i
think that that some
this this acceptance of subjectivity in
the modeling just comes through so
strongly in biology i think it is there
in physics but people kind of deny it
they sort of think of their model closer
to truth
right i mean i and i guess the um i
guess you know if uh the ambition in
physics is
somewhat different
right uh the ambition was to always get
down to the fundamental building blocks
right so you know finding out about the
quarks you know after having you know
cracked the atom and so on going all the
way down to quarks
that was the ambition about going to one
of the fundamental building blocks even
though we know that in order to
understand
you know the motion of
this you know um
our moon or planets in the solar system
it's utterly irrelevant how many quarks
they are and what flavors they are right
um a description of that level of the
system it comes back to the mapping and
your analogy with if you're just walking
along foot paths in the lake district
you don't need to know where the
motorways are right and and i think that
maybe the difference you know i'm really
trying to understand as you can see
they're trying to grapple
one of the ways you know physics and
biology are two different ways of
knowing the world
and
what
how are they different are they
different i think they are different and
i'm trying to get at
how they are different um you know in a
in a very basic
uh in the most sort of boiled down way
so what what is really different
and one of the ways i sometimes
summarize it i i
i i have this ml in the physical world
thing and i use conway's game of life
and i sort of say
because i use quotes from laplace that
say the laplace determinism which by the
way his whole book was about probability
and the determinism you can't get away
with it so it's so weird that that's
associated with it but the plastic
determinism the superman quote um if an
intelligence could understand where
everything is and all the laws of nature
we can predict the future
um and then i show um conway's game of
life which has just three very very
simple rules
and
point out that there's something called
a loafer which is an emergent phenomena
in that game that wasn't discovered
until 2013 and the effective god of the
game
the god of the game conway himself
didn't know it existed so when you go
back and you read these lovely hawking
quotes for them we would know the mind
of god well but you you know the mind of
god before all this computation has to
follow from those physical laws and the
three ways in which uncertainty can
creep in that is really comes through in
that last quote one is because he says
he says uh would know that the
situation of all beings in the universe
so that's the data the natural laws by
which they're governed so that's the
model and then of course that
intelligence has sufficient
uh it's a sufficient intelligence to
subject this data to analysis he says or
something like this um and that's the
compute and one of the things with
biology it is so distant down the
compute
in terms of to reconstruct what's
happened and then when you consider
evolutionary that we're actually seeing
the consequences of billions of years of
evolution as well in order to sort of
compute this i mean the the whole thing
with cotway and it took us because you
have to do all that computation all that
exploration of a very relatively simple
thing to find these emerging phenomena
and i just think that physics is quite
close to oh well what are the underlying
things going on with these pixels why
are they disappearing in game of life
and biology is saying okay that's nice
that that's going on but you know
they've shown that the game of life is a
turing is cheering complete so this
thing can compute anything why is it
doing that and when does it do that
um
i mean that to me is a really major
difference
sarah yeah so
yeah i
i try to always see the similarities
and you know i'm i'm
20 in the department of physics at the
university of cambridge and the
cavendish lab
in theory of condensed matter where you
have you know at a sort of sociological
level you've got the theorists which is
the group that i sit in you've got
experimentalists
and in many ways there's the same kind
of dynamics you know that you have in
biology um
having having said that i mean a living
you know even a living organism like
like the e coli cell that i was showing
in that simulation that neil kind of
remembered with all these jiggling
protein complexes
you know it it's got 4 000 genes that
the number of interactions is kind of
you know combinatory explosion of that
um
and
and yeah the complexity of it is just
it's a different level you've got you
know these circuits but a lot of hugely
feedbacks and and robustness redundancy
and and all these things we've discussed
kind of built into the system and that
is different from let's say a
crystalline material you know
water ice
um
you know these these materials have been
studied for for decades in and
modeled and so on in
in
theory of condensed matter and so that's
in fluid dynamics and so i mean that's
that's really different i mean it's the
level of complexity the number of
components the number of interactions
and so on i think ultimately that's what
determines
um
well and then going back to sort of
you know the protein folding program
problem underneath it you've still got
all that complexity about why what the
interactions are in the molecular bonds
that cause them to
to fold as as well
well
if you take protein folding you know the
number of
different atoms in one single 100 amino
acid polypeptide chain
is is
like it's 2 000 or so and then they can
all be interacting in different ways
with each other and and that's why that
problem still isn't solved
but there's still some
you know to draw out the similarities
and then i'm going to
talk about it's not work i do but bing
ching chang who's one of the fellows in
um our accelerate program she's looking
at trying to understand the behavior of
water under extremely high temperature
and massively high pressure and she ends
up in this problem with you know trying
to do all the sort of um
i don't know the schrodinger equations i
don't even remember all this sort of
details of what what you would see sort
of doing at the low level what's going
on those bonds and she has to simulate
it and she's still in that position
of not actually being able to do
sufficient compute to simulate this this
very simple substance that sarah said
very well studied but apparently one of
the things that she said that just blows
my mind this is the state that most
water of the universe is in because it's
mostly in the heart of
very large ice planets um or gas gas
giants
um you know and we don't even understand
that the phase that this water is in and
whether it's super conducting and which
i think the implication it is um and
it's for the same sort of reason that
you can't do that simulation at real
speed and and she ends up doing the same
type of thing that i think is possible
in many of these things is replacing the
actual complexity of the underlying
physics which with an abstraction that
captures the salient part for the
simulation you're doing and i think that
that's a commonality everywhere that i
mean that's what that's what i
think of when i think of machine
learning in the physical world the
ability to find the savior part of the
system that you're looking at and
abstract it into something where you can
compute that much quicker so that you
can actually do your simulations to
predict the thing you're interested in
um oh this has been fascinating i i feel
very i've been very selfish i think we
should open up to the floor to see if
our audience has um
any questions um
so i think um given um that uh we had a
very tight assembly today in order to
ensure that the proceedings were smooth
uh people can unmute themselves and ask
the question ask questions if they like
uh priya sorry it's ty the only problem
is that may we may have been uh editing
problems
with that um i don't know oh i see okay
we should go with the chat okay if you
don't mind i'm sorry oh not at all
that's fine
now please uh go ahead and type
any questions that
you might have
in the chat as per usual
and i guess as we wait for uh
people to um
start framing their questions
you know um
one um aspect of these biological
systems that
i find incredibly fascinating which
again is very similar to the kinds of
systems that i work on is the temporal
scales over which these systems have
functioned
optimized and operated right sort of
evolutionary uh time scales
and i i wonder when as you are
uncovering these sort of complex
relationships
um
you know is there um
is there interest in understanding sort
of the evolutionary pattern and i mean
evolution not in darwinian but you know
the changes over time like that along
the temporal axis
yeah i think that's a that's a really
nice analogy between biology and
astronomy cosmology and so on um
i mean there's there's a lot of i
thought we would talk more actually
about temporal dynamics and you know
correlation causation because
that's one way that you can
you know you can you could you get can
get a better handle on causation if
there's a temporal sequence
um
but
and and and
so so modeling
dynamics is is in you know in biological
systems and i showed the you know the
flight development is one example
there's basically a progression
happening there from the early embryo
you know through development
um
that that's a
a
you know that that's a really important
element of genomics and uh uh
data models and so on and so forth it's
i would say the the evolutionary
sort of you know evolutionary dynamics
is a bit of a different problem so if
you are thinking about darwinian
evolution because of course everything
that we see nowadays is kind of a
snapshot of the current time and it's
it's only things like um you know
digging out woolly mammoths and that
kind of thing that can allow us to
actually get an idea of of
um
of what happened before the current time
kind of an evolution but it's it's a fad
that's also fascinating
so there's a related question uh that
rick from our evolutionary biologist has
put in the chat and his question is i
wonder whether systems biology
based on single cell transcriptomes is
ready to investigate the agency of
tissues signaling centers electrically
coupled cell aggregations and mechanical
forces in organismal development
um
so signaling for sure
um
i mean in in the sense that you know i
showed
basically predictions of cell cell
communication through
sort of receptor ligand complementarity
and you can then link that downstream to
signatures of expression downstream of a
receptor you can link it to this is with
your kovid example right this was now
this one so this was the placenta that
is
how the signaling takes place between
the
you know how how signaling takes place
between the fetal cells and the maternal
immune cells and prevents rejection
right basically so that's there there's
a huge signaling circuitry basically
that ensures that that's very robust and
redundant actually tons of mechanisms
there to ensure that tolerance and
support of the the placenta um i mean i
didn't go into all the molecular details
um
so so that's certainly um you know
single cell transcript transcriptions
are very informative there they're
they're um
i mean there are also methods that
couple the single cell transcriptomes
with electrical signals a patch seek is
a technology where you couple the patch
clamp
of a single cell and measure the
electrical signal the conductance and
then link that to the transcriptome by
then sequencing the content of what's
inside the cell that you suck up in the
in the pipette um
and and and mechanical forces i would
say
um
there are various ways of that i think
are very exciting going forward to link
kind of mechanical properties of cells
to the single cell transcriptomes and
one is to read out the molecules
that determine
the the mechanical stiffness of a cell
or the morphological properties of a
cell and um and link the the images that
you have of a tissue section
in terms of the morphologies the shapes
of the individual cells to the
the transcriptomes that you sequence
from each
voxel each basically spatial
um you know uh
xy coordinate basically in the tissue
section
so there are there are various ways of
getting at these these properties
by by coupling the single cell
transcriptomes of you know as well
integrating other kinds of data
and i think so it's a great question
richard thank you
yeah and um we have a question from
jenny
who asks
that yesterday you said that the
predictive power is reduced with an
increased amount of data
is this really true isn't it rather
possible that the predictive power of a
model
is reduced at the scale that we are
currently looking at it but may still be
strong on a more detailed level
no so i think that was a
misunderstanding so so
the predictive power of the modeling is
definitely increased with increasing
amounts of data there's no question
about that
the plot that i was showing was data on
on the x-axis
and knowledge and expert knowledge input
on the y-axis and basically on the
left-hand side if you have less data you
need to input more expert knowledge to
interpret that data on the right-hand
side with the high kind of data on the
x-axis tons and tons of data
the the modeling the signal is so strong
well that you don't know
yeah yeah exactly that's what it was
trying to say i hope that makes sense
jenny
and i'm sorry if it was yeah great
so um i think there's a question from
fedoz
um and he says you know can you work as
described yesterday in part um in either
part one or part two could that shed
light on dna double strand breaks and
repair
and you know and he's um
his uh question is from the context of
you know harmful dna damage caused by
ionizing radiation
and i recently came across the following
article and summarized double strand
breaks are a type of dna damage that
could be repaired
by two major cellular pathways
non-homologous end joining during which
the insertions or deletions may be added
at the break site or a homologous
recombination in which the dna sequence
often remains unchanged
conditions in space i guess he's
referring to a lot of the data we got
out of scott kelly's time and the length
of the telomeres and you know the
changes the sort of molecular level
changes from exposure to radiation he
had from his long sojourn at the
international space station right and
so he's asking whether the crispr cast 9
gene editing system offers a model for
the safe and targeted generation
of double-stranded brakes in eukaryotes
and would a crispr based assay for dna
break induction
um
and um
yeah so he wants to know if crispr cas9
would deliver
um
[Music]
so so i would sort of say that the
um
the the
the transcriptomic readout of a cell
can tell you about mutations only in the
regions that are transcribed
obviously and and you also need to have
a reference
to the
non-mutated reference basically so that
can be another cell
or it can be a you know a reference dna
sequence
and and in that way by by aligning
comparing data you can make inferences
about mutations
um
but can you fix that
and and
well you can i mean you can
i guess the way
um
so you so cell-based therapies
for for instance rare diseases for
cancers or for rare genetic disorders
they are kind of fixing mutations by
delivering cells
well you could either use crispr yes to
fix the mutation delivery deliver the
the the enzyme with with the guide rna
to the cell
or you could actually deliver kind of
substitute cells
that are healthy basically
yeah
um
i don't think i'm missing any um
questions yet um
please feel free to have a few more
minutes before we uh wrap up because we
could keep going uh this has been such a
wonderful session but it's getting late
for sarah and neil
and
are there any uh further questions
ty did i miss anything
i didn't see any nope
great so i guess before we wrap up i
would like both of you to
tell us briefly uh what are the next uh
next exciting steps in both of your
research directions very very curious to
know what it is that you're really
thinking about right now
and now what's very exciting
well i i think from for me basically the
um
you know the map of all the tissues in
the human body and this
i think really interesting from our
discussion is also you know what's the
right level of mapping the human body we
obviously have a pretty good knowledge
of our organs you know but a much less
uh accurate knowledge of the cells in
our body
and actually you know how
what are the ways in which that
very highly resolved single cell
knowledge of full molecular breadth one
of the ways in which that
in in in which that is informative and
what are the ways in which that's not so
the human styleless project you know
where
where are the areas where it can really
impact uh on human health on on
understanding
or where the way is it actually a higher
level map a more coarse ground map or a
more detailed map you know going down to
the atomic level
are are actually better descriptions of
our body um i mean i think those are
those are really interesting questions
um you know for me
the applying the power of these highly
resolved and spatially resolved genomics
technologies
to
um
uh the body the immune system
uh uh the components of the immune
system in our bodies is gonna be
uh you know the direction of travel for
the coming years and expanding that to
the human genetics scale and
understanding
you know how we vary from each other
across
human beings across the globe you know
we're we're obviously different from
each other you know in subtle ways in
this group and there's more diversity on
earth as a whole and can we understand
that at the cellular molecular level
using these highly resolved technologies
and gathering even more big data on
making a cell atlases of lots and lots
of tissues of hundreds and thousands of
people
um and interpreting them with
you know anneals gaussian process latent
variable models or other machine
learning methods i think is is a really
exciting way forward in this whole
paradigm that we've discussed where we
use
genomics technologies that generate big
data sets and then
use
statistical computational machine
learning methods to interpret them and
iterate on that in this let's go let's
call it a new paradigm of science you
know whether whether whether it's really
completely new or not i think we've
discussed that here and it's been really
wonderful and fun to track you both
and uh neil what about you
what is the
exciting pleasures i get is i get to
listen to like the sort of things
sarah's gonna do and think oh and maybe
i can help
but um
and that is a really great pleasure and
something i i really enjoy and i think
comes in terms of immediately achievable
aims um
there's a lot of projects it's one of
the great things in machine learning
like that i mean sarah's probably you
know
the most interesting
but i think there's another another
thing i'm interested in and don't really
have a handle on how to attack and maybe
this is like a 10-15 year thing
but i think that there's sort of a
smooth path i mean i think it's a
serious problem is that as we
we've talked a lot about how these
methods are used in computational
biology but of course these methods are
being deployed across society and when
you think about them in the sort of
social context i mean naive use of these
methods has led to all sorts of problems
you know filter bubbles um manipulable
elections and so on so forth
and
this leads to a thought for me that is
um you know we cannot be in a world
where
we are
um being operated on by the whim of
these techniques and the only way we can
turn that around is by gaining more
control over what these things are doing
and what does that mean for the normal
people what does that mean to produce
techniques that normal people
feel in control of that are dictating
things about how their lives are carried
out and i i mean i think that's a very
difficult question and there's this sort
of
easy engineering answers and sort of
very difficult sort of answers about
what that could look like so that's
something i'm very very
interested in um but it's kind of it's
actually extremely hard to publish
stuff in this area and it's extremely
hard to get everything in place that you
need to do work in this area so that's
why it's great in the meantime i also
get to uh um work with sarah's team or
my team works with service team on on
some of these things that we've perhaps
answered more immediately
great um
thank you thank you so much uh both of
you for absolutely fascinating
conversation today and sarah once again
thanks for the brilliant talk yesterday
and you're
a very patient composer through the
disruptions as well
so um i just want to say thanks to the
audience
oh i think there's a question that has
just popped up um
let me um
oh this is tyler uh tyler who says you
know jose ortega
garcia argues
fascinatingly that the phrase missing
the forest for the trees is
fundamentally incoherent forest sea
offers don't actually exist out there
in the nominal world but instead
represent the sensation of being
confronted the inscrutable vastness of a
grove of trees to understand what a
forest is is in other words is precisely
to miss the forest for the trees is
there a sense in which neil's big data
paradox is a feature and not a fault
and it's a great question a great
question part of what we're saying yeah
i think that the problem is we don't
have control over that yeah so um
i don't think i i would disagree
that it's fundamentally coherent and i
think i'm missing its coherence is
misunderstanding this point about
abstraction
what is important if i'm the forestry
commission working out how much wood i'm
going to grow next year it's my number
and scale of forests perhaps less the
individual trees it depends what i'm
doing and this is kind of what i mean
about metal reductionism that it's
subjective the answer to that the
problem we face with the big data
paradox and it is something that
technically i am interested in how you
solve it and actually gaussian processor
latent variable models do offer a
solution this is the thing that
sarah is uh using in her team is that
you you you miss this ability to control
whether you're looking at the forest or
the tree you're like classical
statistics gives us the forest we
understand very well how it gives us the
forest and why
and then we think we're gonna get a
little section of the forest but we go
immediately all the way down to a leaf
and some insect on it we don't manage to
get to the sort of the structure we're
interested in because we don't have the
sort of dial to move around these things
so i don't think it's incoherent in a
statement but i do think um what you
want is the ability to move smoothly
across the spectra and you kind of want
that across all sciences and it relates
very closely to this just you know i
think that those spectra is kind of like
between physics and biology and things
like that
yeah um and i think um we will let's
close with that um
uh very very nice uh question and i
think you know i'm just very tempted to
make one small comment is that you know
often they have been sort of uh you know
the sociologists of science have often
critiqued narratives of science that
scientists offer in which they separate
out the context and the context doesn't
really matter because of
this sort of you know um slim uh notion
and understanding of objectivity and and
i think that the context really matters
and i think both neil and sarah are
telling us that the kinds of questions
you ask and what question you ask really
depends on the context and what you know
what is it that informs the question is
almost as important as the question
itself
right
so um thanks everyone for this wonderful
session and i thank you both and um see
you all at um the next uh next month's
colloquium bye take care and thank you
thank you